anyone who watches Dance Moms knows that
Abby Lee Miller likes to make fun of
people and criticize her dancers so
we're not surprised that her students
mothers clash with her every now and
then but let's be real
these Dance Moms also clashed with each
other we found some of the biggest mommy
meltdowns of all time so watch until the
end to find out which Dance Moms
explosive episode puts everyone else's
to shame Cathy goes rogue Abby has a lot
of enemies but none of them are as
dedicated as Cathy Nesbit Stein
before opening her very own studio
Cathy's daughter vivianne used to dance
at Abbey school but feuds between mother
and teacher soon made working together
impossible so despite leaving Dance Moms
in season one Cathy remained determined
to make Abby's life a living hell from
afar in season 3 episode 7 Cathy and her
crew attend a dance competition and
guess what Abby's group is also
competing for the title but instead of
letting their dancers performances do
the talking Cathy goes rogue and tries
to provoke Abby's temper Cathy blatantly
makes fun of Abby students for riding in
a white van and she flaunts her
limousine for all to see surprisingly
Abby remains calm for the first few
moments that is until Cathy insults her
hairstyle by now it's clear that Cathy
cares more about pushing Abby's buttons
than winning the competition and it
looks like she's not the only one this
is made obvious when dance dad Rick soon
jumps in to give Abby a piece of his
mind Cathy and Rick are not letting Abby
go without a fight
but despite having valid reasons to be
angry Cathy's shrill voice and
hysterical ways make it impossible to
side with her
Jill bites back Kendall and her mother
Jill first appeared in the second season
of Dance Moms and although things ran
smoothly at first
Jill slowly began bumping heads with
Abby and the other moms with the
exception of Melissa of course Jill
isn't one to bite her tongue and let her
daughter be ridiculed so we weren't too
surprised to see her nerves bubble up
and see
five episode 25 Jill's sour attitude
turned bitter real quick and before long
she was ready to bite Abby's head off
so when Kendall's posture got picked on
a second time still basically exploded
instead of backing down and letting Jill
get her two cents in
Abby retaliated with a full-blown attack
and we wouldn't expect anything less
from the dance teacher meanwhile Jill
blamed her daughter's lack of
flexibility on the fact that Abby hadn't
hosted a stretching class in a long time
but according to Abby her dancers are
supposed to stretch before entering the
studio so how did this fight end well
with Kendall bursting into tears of
course after getting some lip from Jill
Abby decided to let Kendall out of class
early which only added fuel to the fire
but after seeing her daughter in tears
it looks like Jill chose to quit while
she was ahead Christy's meltdown being a
parent is hard enough as is but your job
can become even more hectic when your
kids got a dream Chloe's mom Christi is
no stranger when it comes to fighting
with other moms and Abby but she's not
usually one to have a meltdown in broad
daylight but this is exactly what
happened in season 1 episode 2 being a
dance mom is no joke which is why the
moms are usually exhausted hungry and
ready to rumble but what happens when a
mom of two is way behind on her workload
and stuck in a dance studio well nothing
good that's what at this point Christi
is clearly overworked and desperate to
get at home on top of that she isn't
feeling like the best mother and this is
because Chloe is starving and about
ready to collapse
she needs to go home and eat dinner but
not just that I need to go home on top
of that Christy has been trailing her
young daughter Clara around since the
early morning and let's face it
Abbey studio isn't the best place for a
toddler to be we're so used to seeing
Christy yell and cause a scene that seen
her in this state is totally weird not
only is she out of character but she's
also vulnerable and an inch away from
having a full-blown burnout well we're
happy that the lukasi axe went home and
had a good night's sleep because well
they definitely deserved it
Holly axe unholy well he might be the
calmest dance mom around
but that doesn't exempt her from the
occasional meltdown
what sets Holly apart from the other
moms is that she only gets into fights
when her daughter Nia is being attacked
by Abby or when another member of the
team is being treated unrightfully so
some might even say that holly is the
dance moms guardian angels in season 5
episode 2 we see Holly come to life when
one of her friends gets insulted the
fight breaks out when Abby accuses Jilla
being a bad mom and she takes things a
step further by insinuating that Kendall
is a spineless puppet luckily for them
Holly comes to the rescue
things escalate when Nia tells Abby that
she's disrespecting everybody and Holly
jumps in to shine some light on Abby's
disgusting behavior but instead of
having a real conversation like a normal
person would Abbey threatens to kick
Holly off of the show at this point it's
clear that holly has left the building
and left her alter ego in charge she
points her finger in Abby's face while
telling her that she's not the enemy
which is more than a little misleading
but like the classy lady she is holly
speaks her mind instead of becoming
violent as some other moms would have
this mommy meltdown is quite surprising
but it's nothing compared to the last
one we're going to show you so sit tight
because drama is coming your way
Melissa loses our cool it's a well-known
fact that Abby favors Maddie over the
of her students so it's not surprising
that Melissa and the other moms bump
heads every once in a while but in
season 2 episode 22 things get a little
out of hand
Christi and Melissa get into a huge
fight which ends with Melissa storming
off according to Christi melissa is a
cheater who talks badly about Chloe and
other children so Christi goes a little
too far and insults Melissa in front of
everybody on top of calling Melissa a
liar Christi goes in for the kill by
bringing up her living situation she
accuses her of sleeping with her boss
and living with a married man and let's
just say that Melissa doesn't take the
insult too well according to the other
Dance Moms melissa is a trouble maker
who is also extremely smart
so she tends to play her cards just
right by the end of this episode melissa
is storming out of Abby's studio with
little Mackenzie in tow with emotions at
an all-time high Melissa's daughter is
showcased crying over the fact that the
other moms are ganging up on Melissa
this mummy meltdown brings another issue
to light and it highlights how far
Christi will go to win a battle minister
dawn is at it again we don't know about
you but we can't get enough of minister
dawn despite only making a few
appearances in season 1 Don managed to
create some pretty unforgettable
scenarios having previously been kicked
out of Abby's studio didn't sit well
with her especially since she was
escorted out by the police at first Don
was upset because her daughter Regan was
kicked out of the class for
disrespecting the dress code and the
fight escalated to the point that Don's
contract was cancelled but in season 1
episode 7 Don is called back to settle a
missing payment issue this mommy
meltdown is unlike anyone we've ever
seen and this is because Don managed to
keep her emotions in check this time
around but the smug look on her face
says it all by now we all know that Abby
loves taking people to court even when
she's the one to blame
Susie thorns to Sudan for disrespecting
the contracts rules but let's just say
that
mr. Don is asking herself what would
Jesus do because she's nowhere close to
being as hysterical as she's been in the
past
instead of being escorted out Don takes
the highway and leaves a be fumbling
with the bill
jessalyn goes after sherry Dance Moms is
an unpredictable show and although some
moms will join the production as friends
they'll end the series as worst enemies
or vice versa
jessalyn and sherry might have been best
buds prior to becoming Dance Moms but
their love for each other came to an
abrupt end in season 2 episode 9 Jojo
isn't the easiest kid to deal with and
this has everything to do with her poor
attitude and huge ego but that doesn't
make it okay for grownups to pick on her
instead of defending Jessa Lin's kid
sherry is laughing at Cindy's jokes
however she doesn't have the slightest
clue that Jess Elena is bubbling with
rage so poor sherry never sees Jessa
Linds outburst coming by now it's
obvious that Sherry's not getting off
the hook
so she decides to yell back at jessalyn
who's not going to back off any time
soon after being yelled at for a little
too long
sherry loses her cool and accuses Jess
Elena being a bully and we can't say
that she's wrong although she might
chalk it up to defending her daughter
jessalyn should have confronted Cindy
and not sherry who is just trying to fit
in with the other moms
jessalyn is no stranger when it comes to
mommy meltdowns but then again none of
the Dance Moms are the bus starring Abby
and Christi Abby isn't the easiest
person to get along with so it's best to
stay out of her way but sometimes Dance
Moms don't really have a choice in the
matter
dance competitions are supposed to be
fun but Abby isn't one to let her
clients unwind so instead of letting the
moms calm their nerves while on the bus
to the competition
Abby chooses to pick a fight with
Christi
you can tell by the look on Christy's
face that she wasn't expecting to get
singled out what's worse is that she's
clearly not in the mood to deal with a
bee in any way what competitions can be
a stressful time for the girls it's
equally as stressful for the moms so
we're not surprised to see Christy lose
her cool it doesn't take long for
Christy to explode with anger especially
after being called ignorant but
apparently this is what Abby wanted in
the first place
Abby threatens to kick Christy off the
bus which is a little surprising but
most shocking of all is the evil give
all that Abby let slip through her lips
when the topic of Kelly arises but
seriously is that giggle the most
frightening sound you've ever heard
Ashley and Jill go at it when it comes
to defending their daughters each and
every dance mom is guilty of going a
little too far in season six episode
three Jill and Ashley get into a spat
over something extremely childish in
Ashley's mind her daughter Brynn has
done no wrong so she's more than happy
to confront Jill about her ridiculous
theory according to Jill bran is
stealing Kendall's coaching time by
standing in front of her but from where
Ashley's standing Fran isn't bothering
anyone
jewelle adds fuel to the fire she
created by calling friends stupid which
is pretty unforgivable instead of
stooping down to her level
Ashley goes to Abby for advice but
things start to escalate when Jill
approaches Abby with the same matter for
once Abby keeps her cool while Jill
absolutely loses it clearly making
Kendall uncomfortable Jill's meltdown
pits are in a bad light because in the
end she's pointing her finger at a
little girl and calling her stupid
so she's definitely not the winner here
Kelly goes berserk Kelly might have her
moments but she tends to be a pretty big
spaz so many of us expected her to go
berserk after the way Abby treated her
daughter Paige in season 2 episode 14
Abby
wild with fury when PJ's prop is
improperly secured instead of talking to
Kelly one-on-one Abby throws Paige's
chair across the room and cuts her
rehearsal short although Kelly was wrong
and letting her daughter perform without
anti-slip grips on her chair Abby should
never have treated Paige the way she did
so she kind of deserved Kelly's clap
back but after seeing her daughter in
tears Kelly chose to go all the way
[Music]
Kelly informs Abby that she's pulling
her kids out of the studio and canceling
their solos but this doesn't seem to
faze Abby in the slightest
so Kelly decides to take things even
further
[Music]
Kelly is obviously overworked which is
probably why she's having a total mommy
meltdown
but that doesn't mean that she gets to
make fun of Abby's appearance because
let's face it once you bring someone's
looks into it you've already lost the
battle Yolanda's claws come out are you
guys ready for the biggest mommy
meltdown of all time well we hope you
are because things are about to get a
little physical Yolanda and her daughter
Aliannah
were invited to join in a mini
competition in season seven of Dance
Moms and unfortunately things got pretty
ugly pretty fast
apparently Yolanda was accusing
everyone's kids of bullying and
excluding her daughter but when no one
would take her seriously she took it
upon herself to approach the children
bunyan italiana confirmed that her
mother wasn't telling the truth and in a
way Yolanda ended up causing more
problems for her daughter but Stacy's
daughter Liliana wasn't about to let
Yolanda discipline her so she told a
little lie herself by now we all know
that Yolanda wasn't actually yelling at
Liliana but Stacy took her kids words to
heart as any parent would unfortunately
for Stacy
Yolanda just wasn't in the mood for any
more conflict so she tried to settle
things the old-fashioned way talk about
a mommy meltdown right before you go
make sure to tell us which
mother-daughter duo is your favorite in
the comments below and that's the end of
our video if you've enjoyed these mommy
meltdowns as much as we did give this
video a big thumbs up and make sure to
subscribe to the themes for more great
content to come your way thanks for
watching and see you next time
[Music]